Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Ce matin-là, j’avais laissé
mon vélo au garage.
Il faisait froid, il faisait nuit,
c’était en décembre.
Il était 5 h 15 du matin.
J’avais commandé un Uber.
Le chauffeur est arrivé.
J’ai embarqué.
Il a bifurqué sur la 39ᵉ Rue,
puis sur Massachussetts Avenue.
Nous avons passé le Watergate,
le Washington Monument.
Et quand j'ai dit au chauffeur que
j'allais voir le cercueil de George Bush,
il était étonné.
Étonné qu’un étranger se lève
si tôt pour aller voir la dépouille
de son président défunt.
Il m’a parlé de George Bush,
d’autres présidents,
et nous étions déjà arrivés au Capitole.
La grande place devant
le Capitole était vide.
J’étais parti si tôt
pour éviter les queues
et arriver à l’heure à ma séance
de 10 h à la Banque mondiale.
Mais il n'y avait pas de queue.
J’ai passé la sécurité,
traversé les couloirs,
et je suis arrivé
dans la rotonde du Capitole.
Face à moi, le cercueil de George Bush
recouvert d’un drapeau américain.
Et là, une lumière rouge sur une caméra.
Est-ce que j’étais en live sur CNN ?
D’abord, j’ai voulu me cacher,
j’étais gêné.
Et puis j’ai pensé que,
peut-être sans George Bush,
je n’aurais pas pu faire mes études
en ex-Allemagne de l’Est.
Un joggeur est venu
se mettre à côté de moi.
Je l’ai regardé.
Il était en habit de jogging,
chaussures de course à pied.
Je me suis dit :
« On ne peut pas faire ça. »
Puis je me suis rappelé
que je n’étais pas en Suisse.
J’ai pris un bus pour le centre-ville.
J’étais le seul blanc dans ce bus
qui arrivait des quartiers
pauvres de Washington.
Je suis descendu non loin
de la Maison-Blanche
et j’ai marché un bloc
jusqu’à la Banque mondiale.
Je suis arrivé bien à l'heure
pour ma séance de 10 h.
Pourquoi je vous raconte ça ce soir ?
Parce que ce moment m’a marqué.
J’ai eu l’impression d’être le témoin
d’un moment d’histoire des États-Unis,
le témoin d’un moment intime
vécu avec les Américains.
Ce genre de moments est emblématique
de la curiosité qui m’habite.
Le voyageur, il est en mode découverte,
il a ses antennes ouvertes,
il fait preuve de curiosité.
Le voyageur, il n’est pas chez lui ;
il essaye de comprendre.
Il essaye de comprendre sans juger.
Il fait preuve d'empathie.
Quand j’avais neuf ans,
je voulais devenir journaliste.
Je pensais que c’était le métier le plus
à même de rassasier ma curiosité.
Et puis, je me suis rendu compte que
les lieux étaient importants pour moi.
Quand j’allais à l’école de mon village
de Belfaux à Fribourg,
je passais tous les matins
devant la gare des bus de Fribourg
et je voyais des bus
avec des destinations comme
Jaun, Bulle, Avenches, Schwartzsee.
Et plus d'une fois, j'ai rêvé prendre un
de ces bus et m'évader pour la journée.
Le 9 novembre 1989,
le mur de Berlin est tombé.
J'avais quatorze ans.
Je regardais à la télé
ces Allemands de l’Est
qui passaient pour la première fois
à Berlin-Ouest.
Je commençais à m’intéresser au monde,
et à quelques centaines de kilomètres
de mon village,
des gens traversaient un mur,
le sourire aux lèvres.
J’étais fasciné par cette Allemagne
qui se réunifiait
et sans le savoir,
je me préparais au nomadisme.
J’ai passé mon bac à Fribourg
et j’ai décidé de commencer
des études en Allemagne.
J’avais le choix entre Leipzig,
Bayreuth, Mayence, Hambourg et Berlin.
Lors d’un enterrement
à Montagny les Monts,
j’ai demandé à un Berlinois
quel serait son choix.
Et il m’a répondu du tac au tac :
« Geh nach Leipzig,
das ist die Stadt der Optimismus. »
[« Va à Leipzig,
c’est la ville de l’optimisme. »]
J'ai commencé des études de sciences
politiques et d'études africaines
à Leipzig.
J'ai aussi très vite rejoint le chœur
de l'université de Leipzig.
Je voulais chanter du Bach
dans la ville où il avait été cantor.
Le chœur de l’université de Leipzig
est vite devenu ma « stammtisch »,
au premier sens du terme,
pour toutes les bières
et les discussions que nous avions
après les deux répétitions hebdomadaires
dans une kneipe,
mais aussi ma stammtisch
au sens plus large du terme,
pour toutes les rencontres et les amitiés
que j’ai pu nouer avec d’autres choristes,
dont beaucoup venaient
de l’ex-Allemagne de l’Est.
C’était la première fois
que je partais vivre à l’étranger
et j’ai dû apprendre
à avoir le mal du pays,
de m’ennuyer de mes montagnes,
de ma famille, de mes amis.
Le voyageur, il a besoin de s’intégrer,
de trouver ses compagnons de route,
ses buddies.
Il cherche le contact.
Pour cela, il a besoin d’une stammtisch.
Le voyageur, il vient de quelque part.
Il y a bien un endroit
où son voyage a commencé.
Il a des racines, un terroir.
Il n’oublie pas d’où il vient.
Il a toujours un morceau
de gruyère dans sa poche.
J’ai continué mon voyage à Dakar
ou j’ai étudié une année,
puis à Berlin ou j’ai travaillé
pour la télévision française.
Et après huit ans passés en Allemagne
et au Sénégal, je suis rentré en Suisse.
Il y a cinq ans,
mon épouse, mes deux enfants et moi-même
sommes partis à Washington.
J’avais décroché un contrat de quatre ans
à la Banque mondiale.
Ce job, dès que j’en ai entendu parler,
je me suis dit : « Je le veux. »
et j’ai commencé à écrire ma lettre
de motivation dans ma tête.
J’ai eu de la chance, je l’ai eu,
mais je me suis vite rendu compte que
partir seul à Leipzig avec deux valises,
c’est différent
que de partir avec sa famille,
un container de 40 pieds et un chat
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique.
Quand vous déménagez avec votre famille,
c’est comme si vous déménagiez une PME.
Il faut que toute la petite entreprise
y trouve son compte.
Il nous a tous fallu plus ou moins de
temps pour nous acclimater à Washington
et moi, j’ai appliqué la méthode CESG -
curiosité, empathie,
stammtisch et gruyère -
que je ne connaissais pas
encore à l’époque.
La curiosité.
Avec ce vélo, j’ai parcouru des centaines
de miles dans Washington, pour voir.
J'ai vu les manifestations
de Black Lives Matter.
J’ai vu les gens qui faisaient la fête
devant la Maison-Blanche
le jour de l’annonce
de la victoire de Joe Biden.
Et j’ai vu les barrières fleurir
dans tout Washington
suite à l'attaque du Capitole.
Pour l’empathie,
je suis arrivé à Washington
avec des lunettes européennes,
ou je devrais dire peut-être même
des lunettes fribourgeoises.
Et je me suis rendu compte que
mes lunettes étaient très différentes
des lunettes américaines.
On a l’impression, parce qu’on regarde les
mêmes séries télévisées, les mêmes films,
que l'on connaît les Américains.
Mais on oublie souvent
que cela fait plus de 300 ans
que notre histoire est différente.
Ma stammtisch, je l’ai trouvée
à la Banque mondiale.
Avec des collègues du monde entier,
on se réunissait
une fois par semaine autour
d’une grande table ronde dans la cafétéria
pour discuter de projets, de dossiers.
Grâce à cette stammtisch,
j’ai trouvé mes buddies,
les collègues avec qui j’ai pu faire
avancer ces dossiers et ces projets.
Certains de ces collègues
sont aussi devenus des amis.
Et le gruyère, le gruyère.
J’avais trouvé dans le Washington Post,
par chance,
un supplément qui paraissait
tous les mercredis, le supplément Food.
Et dans ce supplément, il y avait
un magasin de vins et de fromages
qui faisait de la publicité.
Et quand le gruyère - the real Swiss
Gruyère, not the American one -
était annoncé à 11$ la livre,
j’accourais sur Connecticut Avenue
pour faire le plein de vitamines.
Après quatre ans aux Etats-Unis, nous
sommes maintenant de retour à Fribourg.
Quatre mots : curiosité, empathie
stammtisch et gruyère.
La curiosité, c’est de se laisser aller
dans le choix de ses destinations,
c’est faire ce qu’il faut
pour que les choses surviennent.
La curiosité, c’est le road trip.
Pas celui où vous préparez
tout à l’avance.
Non, le road trip où vous ne savez pas
le matin où vous allez dormir le soir.
Le road trip où vous longez le Mississippi
et où, par hasard, vous tombez
sur le village de Popeye.
Le road trip où vous êtes perdu
au milieu du Kentucky
et que vous voyez sur la carte,
juste de l’autre côté du fleuve Ohio,
une localité dénommée Tell City
pour Wilhelm Tell
et que vous décidez de faire le détour
pour voir cette ancienne colonie suisse.
Et parfois, la vie s'apparente
à un road trip.
Quand un Berlinois me dit
d’aller étudier à Leipzig
et que, sans trop réfléchir,
j’en fais mon choix.
Quand je trouve une petite annonce
à l’université de Leipzig
pour une année d’échange à l’université
de Dakar et que j’en fais mon projet.
Ou bien quand j’entends qu’un job
se libère à la Banque mondiale,
un job très intéressant,
et que je commence à écrire ma lettre
de motivation dans ma tête.
Et encore une chose :
quand je lis dans le Washington Post
que le cercueil de George Bush
sera exposé au Capitole
et que je mets mon réveil
pour le lendemain matin à 5 h.
La curiosité, ce sont mes antennes.
Si la curiosité, ce sont mes antennes,
l’empathie, ce sont mes lunettes.
Quand vous arrivez dans un pays étranger,
vous êtes nouveau.
Les gens voient que peut-être
vous parlez différemment,
que votre apparence est différente,
mais c’est un avantage.
Cela vous permet de poser
toutes les questions,
d’essayer de comprendre
le contexte, les gens.
Mais il y a un danger,
c’est celui de tout ramener à l’endroit
où vous avez vos racines, de vous dire :
« Ah, ça, c’est moins bien que chez moi,
ça, c’est mieux que chez moi. »
Une fois, j’ai posé une question naïve
à un ami est-allemand -
et c’est parfois en posant
les questions les plus naïves
qu’on a les meilleures réponses.
Je lui avais demandé :
« Est-ce que c’était mieux
avant ou après la chute du Mur ? »
Et Micha m’avait répondu :
« Laurent, ce n’était pas mieux
avant ou après, mais c’était différent. »
Et quand vous vous dites que les choses
sont différentes, alors tout change.
L’empathie vient directement
et il n’y a plus besoin de juger
et de se demander
si c’est mieux ici ou là-bas.
Si la curiosité, ce sont mes antennes,
que l’empathie, ce sont mes lunettes,
alors la stammtisch,
c’est le lieu pour cultiver
cette curiosité et cette empathie.
La stammtisch, c’est le lieu pour poser
des questions, écouter, comprendre.
Vous vous rappelez la stammtisch
du bistrot du village ?
Cette table, souvent ronde,
à l’entrée du bistrot,
où des habitués venaient à certains
moments de la journée ou de la semaine.
Ils commandaient une bière,
posaient des questions.
Certains parlaient,
d’autres ne parlaient pas du tout.
Et après deux ou trois bières,
ils repartaient
avec les dernières nouvelles du village
et avec la satisfaction
d'avoir passé un bon moment.
Avec le temps, je me suis rendu compte
que la stammtisch est un excellent moyen
de communiquer et d’échanger.
Et rien de mieux lors de changements que
de pouvoir participer à une stammtisch.
Le gruyère,
c’est mon remède au mal du pays.
C’est mon remède à la nostalgie
des Préalpes de Fribourg
et de tout ce que cette région
représente pour moi.
Le gruyère, ce sont mes racines.
Et comme le gruyère,
je suis un produit du terroir.
En voyage, il est important
de savoir d’où on vient,
de connaître sa culture,
de connaître ses racines.
Et pour le Fribourgeois voyageur,
le gruyère,
c’est aussi une excellente assurance,
une assurance contre le coup de blues
et le mal du pays.
Vous en connaissez d’autres, des produits
fabriqués dans les villages
de notre région,
que l’on retrouve sans trop de problèmes
à Leipzig,
à Washington et peut-être même à Dakar.
Un morceau de gruyère,
un coup de rouge et ça repart.
Voilà mes quatre mots :
curiosité, empathie, stammtisch, gruyère.
La vie est un long road trip.
Et quoi de mieux que d’être en mouvement,
en voyage, pour faire avancer sa vie,
pour trouver les prochaines étapes
et prendre des décisions ?
Quand j’avais 20 ans,
j’ai lu un livre qui m’a marqué,
un livre de Nicolas Bouvier,
« L’usage du monde ».
Et dans ce livre, il y a une phrase
qui est restée dans un coin de ma tête
depuis la première fois que je l’ai lue.
Je vous le dis ce soir,
la vie est un long road trip,
et Nicolas Bouvier le dit beaucoup mieux :
« On voyage pour que les choses
surviennent et changent,
sans quoi on resterait chez soi. »
(Applaudissements)